scientist are using mood drugs to help
dole
learning new skills and improved
cognitive function
let's look at mental a Harvard professor
used on the pencil
drug that's typically used to treat
Alzheimer's to rewire
the brain up a visually impaired woman
after using the drug the woman was able
to process images
the way a newborn wood and eventually
regain normal
site he also uses epilepsy drug called
valproic a
to teach tone deaf adults how to find
musical note
this is pretty amazing stop and these
are just two examples
up this kind of thing I and there they
actually think that there's all kinds a
pill that they can give you that I'll
legitimately make you smarter we did a
story on rewiring your brain last week
that the Internet is actually rewire
your brain could look at bone so much
I are we could have occurred but they're
super humans
on the way we think its robot that are
going to take over but
you know if enough medication is out
there to change the way we think then
the problem is always the side affects
because they always go oh great and then
let go but
you know the Tonga and one walk every
I'm really really Moonwalker I take that
pill it do up to move one the
but no just got a perk really like to
take this pill mill here
sounds take that like it just but also
there's that whole thing it says
the pill helps adult learners passes
babies do
and Lake I was like it with talk about
this whole cognitive processing a
babies have a process information and I
was like really I wanted
it just seems like babies like Ireland
turned
like they don't seem extremely
intelligent image like they really like
but they rightly guided
took you you to walk yeah I michael
myers me to be like Hitler Complaint
Center
I'm yeah Bell retainer for me to like do
the Rubik's Cube yeah I think it's the
rain
that they're learning reentering they
were in just some money right like you
know if you can take a bill to require
brain I would want it quicker than Mike
there are three years yeah
if you could take a pill to be martyrs
what was that movie with the neuro and
yeah
with whatever whatever radical brad Brad
at we day
would you want to take a pill course
what what I read was going to have kids
and it said that you were you says it
like up to six or seven they
really retain a lot and I was like well
I better start getting some classes for
this kid like a big fan of the piano
lessons are some other
you wanted I mean it would be amazing if
I if you could take a Pill
edges retain everything is how many
times have we like for example names
tourney the comedian how many that I
like seeing somebody albeit a
a weekend at a club yeah and is he
bringing the manager and the waitress in
the matter and and just
dunno what their names or anything any
name tags you know it yet you know it's
it is it just feels like that really at
that thing with america
you know with Ron take a pill played out
the way remember them to take a pill
haven't
you read a book I wouldn't you know you
like it it always seems to me like
super it so it was the bath got alright
yeah but I mean
this study was really exciting because
it it would help people like traumatic
brain injuries so I'll give you that but
like
some fat ass on a couch like raquet
remember anything amidst our pop in
these pills right so I am I will say it
again I am extrapolating a bit yet it is
being used for medical purposes and
we're just taking it to the next step
area necessarily
diet behind all this but would pardon
the problem be the only rich people
would be or at least wealthy people
would be able to afford this stuff and
then you're gonna have not just
a divide by economics but literally a
smart divide
yeah process its I mean hopefully if
this technology ever came
to fruition and everyone could could
partake in it but because that's how
everything works right at something good
happens after I get it we're not but
it's like i mean
the unfortunately you're right it's it's
the spill cultural ago I'll just take a
pill you smarter and the unfortunate
thing is we don't put money towards
education we don't
we don't help the poor you know giving
them opportunity in raising them and and
so you think I'll take a pill you
smarter
we have a capacity for being smarter but
now how are they getting smarter if you
know if you're not teaching them
its it's very complicated the FAA says
that you have to take a pill
yeah things will be fine